معنى من في اوكرانيا مراسل الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم مازن اذا الجيش الاوكراني يقولوا
ان القوات الروسيه استهدفت منشاه زراعيه
لتخزين الحبوب في اوديسا
بالفعل عثمان يمكن الجزم بان حرب الصواريخ
مستمره ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا وحرب
المسيرات واستهداف اوديسا وان كانت وان
كان هذا الاستهداف اقل حده الليله الماضيه
مقارنه بالايام الثلاثه التي اعقبت التوقف
وخروج روسيا من صفقه واتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب الليله الماضيه وفق قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه تم استهداف مقاطعه اوديسا
باربعه صواريخ من نوع كاليبر
الوجهه كانت باتجاه منشاه قالت الاداره
الاوكرانيه بانها لتخزين الحبوب ومنشاه
زراعيه ولم تعطي تفاصيل اضافيه ولكنها
اشارت الى ان هذه العمليه عمليه القصف
كانت مركبه اي على دفعتين تم اطلاق
صاروخين وعندما وصلت فرق الاطفاء والاسعاف
تم اطلاق صاروخين اضافيين ولكن بطبيعه
الحال بالرغم من ان هذا التطور يضاف الى
كل السي السابق ولكن يمكن قول بانه
بالنسبه لاوديسا كمدينه القصف الصاروخي
كان يختلف كليا عن ما سبقناه في الايام
القليله الماضيه تراجعت حدته بشكل كبير
ولكن هذا لا ينفي بان البحر الاسود اصبح
اليوم ساحه متجدده للمواجهه وهو يقترب من
ان يشهد مواجهه كبيره بين الطرفين في
اعقاب كل هذه التهديدات سواء كانت من
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه التي اعلنت
بالامس بان كل السفن الروسيه المتجهه الى
عبر البحر الاسود الى موانئ الروسيه او
الى الموانئ الاوكرانيه المحتله ستكون
هدفا عسكريا وجاء هذا الاعلان في اعقاب
اعلان روسي مماثل وبالتالي يمكن الحديث
حاليا عن ان المرحله السابقه اي العام
الماضي عندما شهدنا نوعا ما في البحر
الاسود من وجود ممرات امنه خففت من
امكانيه المواجهه الحربيه المفتوحه بين
الطرفين وذلك ضمن اطار اتفاقيه تصدير حبوب
فان الامر تراجع الى الخلف ونظر التصعيد
في البحر الاسود مرتفعه جدا للغايه
والجميع يتوجس الان من احتمال استهداف
البوارج والسفن التي تنقل الحبوب في تلك
المنطقه وهذا ما اكدت عليه الاداره
الامريكيه بالامس من خلال احد المتحدثين
باسمها بانها رصدت احتماليه ان تقوم روسيا
بقصف السفن التي تنقل الحبوب عمليا
بالنسبه للقياده الاوكرانيه بالامس بالامس
واضحا عندما اعتبر بان كل هذا التصحيط
الروسي هدفه واضح وهو منع اوكرانيا من
تصدير حبوبها الى الخارج وهو اشار في كلمه
له بان كل ما قامت به دفاعات الارضيه
والجويه الاوكرانيه خففت من وطاه الهجوم
الذي استهدف مقاطعتي نيكولايف واوديشا
ولكنه اشار الى ان غياب المظله الجويه
والمنظومه الدفاعيه الصاروخيه المتكامله
لوقف تساقط الصواريخ باتجاه هذه المقاطعات
هو ما يحول دون توصل اوكرانيا الى انشاء
مظله رادعه ضمن هذه المنطقه وبالتالي
عثمان من الواضح ان تلك المنطقه ستكون
محطه انذار الجميع خلال المرحله المقبله
شكرا جزيلا لك مازن ابراهيم من سلوفيا